right so you're getting ready for
breakfast perhaps right now at 6 18. but
when you think about lunch today
maybe think about helping a good cause
at the same time local jersey mikes all
across the valley are helping out
special olympics southern nevada and
nevada i should say
in the 11th annual day of giving for
jersey mike's joining us this morning to
talk about what's going on today it's
terence thornton from special olympics
of nevada uh terence it's good to see
you again this morning how are you doing
likewise john thanks for having me of
course and uh full disclosure i'm on the
the advisory board for special olympics
nevada
we'll talk about some of the work that's
been going on by special olympics in
just a few moments but first
let's talk about this national day of
giving and how folks can help out
special olympics today
yes so we are so honored that jersey
mike's chose special olympics nevada for
this opportunity
we were supposed to kick this off last
year but unfortunately the pandemic okay
to cut it short
but we are so grateful for to have their
support in the community
also to have the community support to
come out to
any of the jersey mike stores closest to
them to support our nevada athletes
today
nevada had the the polar but not polar
plunge over at cowabunga bay
recently as well so there's there have
been efforts going on by special
olympics nevada all through the pandemic
to try and
uh do good work in the community despite
all the restrictions and
the stipulations that are in place what
is the what are the efforts that special
olympics nevada is doing right now to
help people with special needs in the
community
yes so we are doing a vaccine drive here
in southern nevada
also giving education to our athletes
letting them know that it's safe
and encouraging them to get vaccinated
because that'll allow us to go back to
in-person activities soon um
and you know obviously we're wanting to
continue to do what the state has
mandated us
doing where our mass continues to
social distance and hopefully we can get
beyond this
pandemic and get back in person an
effort as
you and i both know by special olympics
nevada to kind of set up
more of its own opportunities here in
the state and help more people with
special needs across nevada
where do things stand with regards to
fundraising and where do things stand
with regards to maybe enhancing some of
the efforts
in our community yes so like many
non-profits we were challenged because
of the pandemic
in fact our revenue was down about 30
percent
last year because of the pandemic so
this year
that's why efforts like this are so
important to help us to recoup
those dollars to support our programming
here in nevada
as many people know we are looking to
re-establish nevada special olympics
chapter here we're currently partnered
with northern california
but with your support today we are
confident we'll meet our goal
and have a independent special olympics
chapter here in nevada
by the end of 2023. terence good to see
you once again again special olympics
nevada it's more than just sports do a
lot of good work in the community
and while you're grabbing lunch this
afternoon maybe think about jersey
mike's as well
terrance good to see we'll check up with
you a little bit later on